Danny what role did the original Blade
Runner play in your life no seriously
it's a movie that I discovered that at a
very precise moment when I was starting
to dream about the possibility of being
a director discovering what was the job
of a director and I think it's like for
me it's like a very strong example of a
strong director's vision and it's like
movie that aesthetically also blew my
mind at the time I was really hungry for
strong serious science fiction you know
and there's not a lot of very strong
sci-fi movies and and that one was
really really aesthetically blew my mind
and it's a masterwork
Harrison when you were sent the script
what was your reaction to the idea of
returning to this character I was
delighted to be involved once I had a
chance to read the script and see what
the opportunities were for taking
advantage of the audience's knowledge of
Deckard that there that came from the
first film and progressing the character
and and bringing that character into
relationships that I thought were
powerfully emotional and so it seemed
like a great opportunity at that at the
first first time I was involved Ridley
was meant to directed and then when
Denny became involved we met and talked
about it and I was really excited about
it
Roger I understand you and Denis had a
really kind of intense session creating
the storyboards for this film and in it
basically in a hotel room in Canada can
you talk a little bit about what your
early work early ideas were well it
started then
much longer process it wasn't like and
one intense session we started in like
September 2015 and went on to the like
the last day of prep before shooting so
it was quite a long process I mean we
started off just basically going through
the script and thinking well how are we
going to visualize this you know and
Dennis was on board and you know we just
gradually kind of worked it through we
all found different references of
different things and discuss different
ideas about the look and the
architecture and the atmosphere and you
know it's just you know spitballing and
they call over here Dennis California
and 2049 looks like a horrible place to
live how did you make it that way
when I first met Binney I asked him a
fairly simple question I said can you
give me one word that describes the
movie in and he paused and he said
brutality and I said okay great
that's a good start so we took that word
and we basically started with the
spinner because that was going to be the
the language that was going to reflect
on a lot of what the movie looked like
and obviously respecting the original
film and and we arrived at something
that I thought was was very compatible
but it was certainly singular to to
ourselves as well - so Ryan you were
right at home in this brutal landscape
what was it like to to work among these
among these sets yeah well I said to
Danny I asked him to describe all in one
word what it would be like and he said
there's snow
I said I said yeah yes yes that I can do
look this the sets were really the the
level to which they had committed to
this vision you know to walk you know on
to these sets and and you know I
remember one day there was a it was a
1/3 of a page it was like my character
walks up to a desk and I assumed that I
would just go to work and walk up to a
desk but they had turned an entire
soundstage into into a one desk it was
just it was so massive and after Roger
had lit it and it was it was a beautiful
but I was confused you know I said it's
a journey isn't this scene just you know
like 3/4 of a page you know and he said
but it's in the movie isn't it yes well
then it you know it has to it has to
operate under the same rules as
everything else so you know it was a it
was a real experience to to work on that
scale with this level of craftsmanship
and artistry and to really physically
inhabit this what felt like a
functioning universe in a lot of ways
Harrison what was it like to shoot that
fight scene in among the Elvis and
lights it was it was complicated I mean
that what I hadn't reckoned on was that
the lights would make it hard to see
where Ryan was
[Laughter]
and he he dances forward a lot better
than he dances backwards so I hit him
pretty hard one time you know it was it
was complicated complicated to fit in
between them and also to get a sense of
the hologram although we had a live
Elvis impersonator for our amusement but
it was fun it was fun
Ryan was it fun for you yes
Roderick this is a very big movie for
your company Alcon to make why did you
guys decide to bet on such a such a big
in such an ambitious film well I think
it was a combination of things
um one we never would have really jumped
off this bridge unless we come up with
what we thought was a very compelling
story to tell and a very a movie that
could stand on its own yet still live up
to the quality of the first film which
we we felt like the brand the brand of
Blade Runner is quality and and it set
so many standards in artistry and all
the rest of it that in order to actually
do it we were like we have to we have to
strive to be you know the best that we
can be so once once we had the rights we
went and saw Ridley and he was very
enthusiastic to jump on board he
certainly had been waiting for many
years to try to untangle
the rights and so he and Hampton then
got together and came up with the the
basic core of the story then Michael
Green came on wrote a screenplay and you
know Ridley had been speaking Harrison
periodically and then he read the script
and was on board so you know once the
train starts going it's it's it's it's
very exciting it's very exhilarating and
then really couldn't at the time that we
wanted to start he couldn't start and so
we all agreed to try to get another
director and we got didn't he
you know we had worked with Denis and
Roger on prisoners and you know loved
that expense one of our favorite
experiences and you know once we got the
the core together here it's been one of
the best experiences we've ever had on a
movie it was everyone's passion and you
know devotion even the Elvis was he was
all in everyone really cared about what
we were doing and and it's it's you know
and for us we felt like the art was
going to be the commerce so it just
needed to be a great movie you can't
tell what's CG and what's in camera what
was your strategy in terms of the visual
effects well the first thing that we all
decided the writer that starts that that
we will construct as much set as
possible so the actors will be inspired
by the set and they will have to focus
on the and their and on their character
and not on into the environment also for
I will say if I'm a Roger for for uni it
was like a way to will we storyboard
everything but we loved also when the an
actor bring an idea bring there's
something that sparks and and on the
morning to readjust ourself and and very
often there are strong images that are
coming spontaneously on set and I didn't
want when you are
this virtual environment surrounded by
green screens don't have that
spontaneity you don't have that
relationship with acting and cut the
camera and so it was important for me to
have and I'm very grateful that the
production decided to follow to support
that idea to construct all the sets also
it was a way to control the atmospheres
because we were constructing the sets
like an apartment for and as an example
that there's a window we will build the
other Street on the other side and then
the rain in between was be real so Roger
will be able to control the light the
light and in between and this way it
means that there's a tons of CGI in the
movie but it's always - and in the
background are a little elements that
are and I think that the fact that it
looks that real as there's two things
from is first of all all the artists CG
artists that work on this movie most of
them their Bible the way they were
brought to the cinema that's passion for
one of their favorite movie of all time
is Blade Runner also then their level of
commitment was so huge and the other
thing about CG is that at the end of the
day is light it's about light and the
way you lit with the computer and the
backgrounds like so it's all Roger
master you know the way blended the VFX
with that's our saying thank you so much
gentleman